selon le dernier bilan le cyclone dean a
n'a pas tué à la réunion mais les dégâts
sont très importants ainsi des sapeurs
pompiers des bouches du rhône doivent
s'envoler d'un moment à l'autre pour
gagner lee qui a été balayée par des
vents de plus de 250 km 1 dominique
dumas le cyclone dean a est passé très
près des côtes au nord et à l'ouest de
la réunion
si heureusement il n'ya pas eu de
victimes de personnes ont été blessées
des dégâts matériels très importants ont
été causés par les vents soufflant à
plus de 200 kilomètres à l'heure des
dommages spectaculaires comme de gros
arbres sur les maisons
by hand meilleur on entendu un énorme
bruit on s'est aperçu que cette arme qui
a 12 ont qu'a été élagué ya six mois est
tombé comme un château de cartes en fait
et heureusement dix minutes avant on
venait d'enlever la voiture sinon
c'était la voiture qui était écrasée
aussi des arbres ont également écrasé
des voitures heureusement vide de
passagers
les secours sont intervenus redit
centaines de fois il y aussi la
solidarité entre voisins
ma femme m'a appelé m'a dit au gardien
d'une femme qui vient de tomber la
pajero gagner voilà d'amener les à terre
à l'eau j'ai avancé pour voir qu'est ce
qui s'est passé et la jambe cassée donc
j'ai dit bon où il habite m'a dit
habiter château morange pour téléphones
l'ambiance les pompiers ont reçu des
centaines d'appels la moitié des
familles sont toujours sans électricité
lionel jospin a annoncé que des fonds
sont débloqués immédiatement pour les
cases urgents des renforts en hommes
sont également attendues essentiellement
des des amphores en en force de
d'intervention rapide d'edf pour que
nous redressions le son électrique une
cinquantaine de personnes au champ sont
envoyés par la direction générale d'edf
et environ 120 ou 130 professionnels
d'unités d'intervention la société
civile sur les jeux d'hier elle est
folle daddah figure it et civiles qui
vont nous aider à rétablir la
circulation
les pluies torrentielles continueront
encore pendant plusieurs heures 2500
personnes sont toujours dans des centres
d'hébergement
enfin de nombreuses cultures maraîchères
ont été totalement détruites